die af die rote armee fraktion ist teil
der deutschen geschichte ein wichtiges
datum ist der 24 april 1975 zu diesem
zeitpunkt überfällt ein kommando holger
meins
die deutsche botschaft in stockholm das
vorhaben endet in einem blutbad hier in
hamburg im schanzenviertel unterhalte
ich mich im dialog mit einem ehemaligen
mitglied der raf
karl heinz dellwo vor 45 jahren durch
die raf die rote armee fraktion
gegründet
sie ist teil deutscher geschichte wenn
sie auch vergangen hat ist am 24 april
1975 besetzen mitglieder des kommandos
holger meins die deutsche botschaft in
stockholm
einer von ihnen sind sie karl heinz
dellwo das endet in einem blutbad
wenn sie sich an diese besetzung
erinnern ist das noch sehr präsent bei
ihnen
also ich weiß noch ich weiß natürlich
auch alles was wir in dieser besetzung
abgelaufen ist aber die aktion selber
ist jetzt so präsent auch nicht mehr
ich bin jetzt seit 20 jahren aus dem
gefängnis raus und benutzer 95 entlassen
worden und hat sich inzwischen so viel
an anderem ereignet und davor gelagert
dass man schon bewusst sich an diese
zeit verwenden aber der richter würden
sie das denn als wendepunkt in ihrem
leben beschreiben oder gibt es einen
punkt vorher wo sie sagen da es etwas
ganz grundsätzliches bei mir passiert
also für die aktion in stopper nicht als
wendepunkt bezeichnen sondern dass sie
sowieso fraglich nach einem wendepunkt
in einer biografie zu suchen
wenn es aber was entscheidendes gab in
meiner biografie
in dieser zeit nicht an weil es der tod
von holger meins im moma streckt 1974
dieser tod von holger meins von mir und
von anderen damals so interpretiert
worden ist dass unsere gesamte bis dahin
ungesetzte linke praxis als völlig
nutzlos und völlig entwertet vor uns
stand und dass wir aus dieser erfahrung
heraus einfach gezwungen waren uns etwas
neues zu überlegen
oder aber die ganze sache wie zu
verdrängen
und vielleicht in ein anpassungsprozess
einzugehen den anderen gemacht hatten
dann ist es aber dieser tod der der
wendepunkt ist oder der
entscheidungspunkt sagen wir mal so die
die entscheidung zu sagen ich nehme
einen bewaffneten kampf auf bei dem ich
ja auch selber getötet werden kann ist
ja eine ganz bewusste entscheidung
aber ich halte das für endlich gesagt
ich halte das für sehr verkürzt nicht
halte das für sehr verkürzt sozusagen
die raf auf jetzt ihre aktionen zu
reduzieren und aus diesen aktionen etwas
zu erklären es gibt eine zeit davor und
die zeit davor
da sind die entscheidenden prozesse
gelaufen aus denen man sich entschieden
hat dass man gesagt hat ich möchte in
dieser gesellschaft nicht integriert
seien
ich möchte mit dieser alten gesellschaft
die ich als alt nazistische
mehrheitsgesellschaft bezeichnet nicht
in einem boot sitzen und diese
entscheidung sind da und die halte ich
für wichtiger diesen ganzen diesen
ganzen prozess heraus werden dann wo
immer der angefangen hat weiß aber dann
gehen wir von 75 vielleicht wirklich
sieben jahre zurück
bei 68 das wird als einschneidendes jahr
bezeichnet nicht nur wegen der
französischen studentenrevolte sondern
auch vor allen dingen in deutschland
wegen des tods von benno ohnesorg der
wie sich nachher herausstellte von einem
stasi mann erschossen wird
das hat sehr viele provoziert zu sagen
selbst dieser stadt tötet menschen um
eine opposition die sich in diesem staat
breitmacht zu stoppen oder den versuch
zu machen die zu stoppen an sieht das so
empfunden
also ich bin 1967 beim tod von benno
ohnesorg 15 jahre alt gewesen
ich bin jetzt im nachhinein nicht ein
ein politisches bewusstsein andichten
das mich sozusagen zum 68 gemacht ich
bin nicht aber die 68er ich habe das ja
ich habe das mitbekommen in der eifel in
der ich gelebt habe und habe gesehen
dass jugendliche studenten aber nicht
nur studenten aber sehr viele aber
jugendliche einfach in den städten auf
der straße waren und ich war von dem
bedürfnis bestimmt auszubrechen und
etwas ganz anderes zu erleben als das
was meine ganzen jahre lang
alltagserfahrung
einen wahren das heißt ich habe mich
dahin gesehen und ich habe mich ohne ihn
ohne dass jetzt nach politisieren
begründen zu wollen
ich habe da einfach ein die intuitiven
emotionalen zusammenhang gesehen und da
wollte ich ihn und in diesem kontext ist
natürlich der tod von benno ohnesorg den
ich natürlich registriert habe genauso
wichtigen tut den satz das attentat auf
rudi dutschke ein jahr später register
registriert ein habe ist das etwas
gewesen was einen schon persönlich
getroffen hat und was sicher für die
eigene politisierung wichtig ist ich
glaube aber weil wenn wir über diese
zeit reden
das macht auch nicht sinn jetzt einzelne
auch ein zeichen staatsaktionen
herauszugreifen und zu sagen da ist
jetzt was ganz erhebliches passiert
sondern ich glaube wir müssen uns
gedanken darüber machen was ist denn
eigentlich die nachkriegszeit gewesen
was sind wir aufgewachsen nicht und ich
bin natürlich wie alle aufgewachsen in
einem klima des des schweigens in einem
klima des autoritären in einem klima der
hand forderung von von permanente
anpassung und und und und das ist etwas
gewesen ging gegen das man dann als
jugendlicher manchmal schon als kind in
irgendeiner weise ein widerspruch
entwickelt und das ist sozusagen die
dieser vor politische zeit die ich auch
von heute aus betrachtet für wichtiger
halt tatsächlich als diese zeit in der
man dann angefangen hat das was man als
als als emotional widerstand der
widerspruch gefühlt hatte das sozusagen
zu verstehen zu begreifen und in
irgendwelche formen oder parolen oder
oder erkenntnisse dann verzeichnen wir
mal über sozusagen die grundlage dessen
was sie was sie jetzt angesprochen warum
ist das einmal gewalttätig gewesen
warum ist das das andere mal nicht
gewalttätig gewesen
was ist da der unterschied ist dass ein
individuell ist das eine individuelle
entscheidung gewesen
am ende sind es natürlich orient wie
individuelle entscheidungen wenn sie
sehen das vielleicht ich weiß nicht wie
viel 200 oder ich weiß wie viele leute
es waren die sich bewaffnet haben dann
können sie das natürlich sagen ihm im
hinblick auf die vielen anderen die von
revolution gesprochen haben und dieser
so ernst genommen habe dies war
vielleicht auch irgendwann eine
individuelle komponente die die jetzt
wichtig ist dass die einzelnen mehr
erreicht hat oder dass sie das was ich
für für mich in anspruch nehmen würde
vielleicht ein klein bisschen mehr das
gefühl hatten wenn man sich anpasst wird
man untergehen man geht verloren in
diesem system man bleibt nicht mehr bei
sich selber man wird von sich enteignet
und wird zu irgendeiner zu irgendeinem
appendix einer verwertung die ich
natürlich später dann ganz klar als
kapitalistischer verwertung definiert
hätte nicht aber damals einfach nur
gesehen
man steckt in einem system drin dass wir
ein anpassungsleistungen abverlangt an
denen man sich selber wenn man sie wenn
man sie wenn man den entsprechen würde
würde man sich selber völlig aufgeben
und das halte ich für die ist das
entscheidende
ich würde ihn vielleicht gerne auch noch
ein beispiel nennen nicht weil ich hab
mal ein jahr nach meiner gefängniszeit
im hamburger institut für
sozialforschung auch gearbeitet
an der sogenannten protest chronik und
ab recherchearbeiten gemacht und habe
für die zeiten von 1959 60 61 und 62
habe ich recherchiert und finden dann
ich weiß jetzt bis 1960 war unter 1961
finde ich bei der suche nach dem was gab
es am protest finde ich ein bild aus
einer stadt im ruhrgebiet da wird gegen
die umweltverschmutzung die
luftverschmutzung für die kohleindustrie
protestiert
und ich bin damals acht und neun jahre
alt gewesen und ich habe nur eine ganz
klare ablehnung gegen mein lehrer gegen
die pastoren und all diese ganzen leute
gehabt mit denen ich einfach emotional
nichts anfangen konnte nicht und ich
hatte kein kein dezidiertes bewusstsein
über bestimmte politische aktivitäten in
dieser zeit dann sehe ich auf diesem
bild da sehen sie eine arbeitersiedlung
ich glaube ich bin gelsenkirchen ich
weiß es nicht mehr genau da ist ein
riesiges transparent drauf und dieses
transparent da steht wir werden vor gast
da stehen sie 1995 und sagen sich mit
einem mal also das was du damals als
kleiner junge gefühlt hast du das
ablehnt das findest du tatsächlich auch
in diesen aktionen die man dann gesehen
hat von dieser alten bevölkerung
bestätigt wenn sie da geht man ihn und
so weiter diejenigen die für den
judenmord usw
verantwortlich sind stellen sich auf
einmal hin und stellen sich sozusagen
als als opfer
da und übernehmen auch noch die sache
mit dem verkehr vergast sein
und das meine ich damit dass man in
seiner bald alle diejenigen ich weiß
jetzt wie alt sie sind sind ja auch
nicht viel jünger aber doch etwas jünger
als als ich aber diejenigen die wie ich
1950 51 52 geboren worden sind die die
haben ja diese ganze alte nazi
gesellschaft sozusagen als als als
gesellschaft ohne nazi ideologie aber
mit allen wasser drin steckte mit mit
dieser konditionierung zu härte mit mit
mit disziplin mit militärischen gehorsam
und so weiter das haben die haut nach
sozusagen kein erlebt man hat sich nicht
mehr getraut hinzugehen hat heil hitler
geschrieben das ist damals dass das ging
nicht mehr
aber diese ganzen mentalitäten die aus
dem nationalsozialismus kamen die sind
ja da gewesen und und die haben wir
gespürt und die hat man intuitiv
abgelegt meine ganze jugend ist davon
geprägt kann ich nur sagen von irgend
einen widerspruch gegenüber dem was sie
dann autoritäten nachbarn alte leute
oder sonstwas nennen
älter ich wurde hier weniger wollte ich
mit ihnen zu tun haben und ja eine ganz
wichtige rolle hat ja gespielt die
hausbesetzer szene auch für sie selber
wir sitzen ja im schanzenviertel in
hamburg
warum war die hausbesetzer szene so
entscheidend auch für den für die
rekrutierung sagen wir mal der raf oder
der gruppen der raf wer hat hierzu in
rekrutiert also die die hausbesetzung
1973 die ist natürlich wichtig gewesen
für einige für diejenigen die damals
waren beteiligt waren ich glaube es
waren ungefähr 70 personen am anfang das
hatte ich den befunden der 120 oder so
was mit der zeit erhöht und das ist eine
hausbesetzung gewesen ich habe vor
kurzem interview mit jemand von einer
englischen tageszeitung gehabt der hat
gesagt ich habe jahrelang in einem
besetzten haus gewohnt ich habe nicht
verstanden warum das in deutschland so
ein wirbel macht bei uns hat man nie
etwas gemacht
bei unserer hausbesetzung unsere
hausbesetzung ist so aufgefasst worden
als hätten wir eine bewaffnete aktion
durchgeführt die hausbesetzung ist nach
sechs wochen oder und ungefähr ist sie
beendet worden
durch einen einsatz des militärischen
einsatzkommandos mek es das war der
erste einsatz den sie hatten dass es
eine von diesen gruppen die waren 1972
nach dem attentat auf die olympischen
spiele gegründet worden
und die hat man gegen hausbesetzer ein
gesetze sind bei uns ins haus rein
gekommen
die haben das ist jetzt nicht meine
behauptung gibt polizeifilm gerne
nachlesen
da wird das als großer als großer
taktischer zug selber dargestellt wie
haben scharf geschossen in dem haus um
um jeden widerstand sozusagen von
vornherein zu brechen schießen sie mal
in so einem alten haus kommen es sei
niemand verletzt worden ist oder so was
und das ist eine mentalität gewesen als
ein feind da ist der feind den feind
muss man niedermachen so der ist da
überhaupt nicht existieren und wenn sie
schon ein kleines moment von der
eigentumsordnung in frage stellen
das ist die mentalität damals gewesen
dann zählen die schon zu denen die
niedergeschlagen und gebrochen werden
müssen das war die hausbesetzung in der
hofstraße und 1973 und die staatliche
reaktion darauf deswegen ist die
natürlich wichtige spiel ein jahr danach
ins gefängnis gekommen
ich bin isoliert worden vom ersten tag
an als einer der wenigen die vollständig
isoliert worden
was unverständlich jetzt unter isolation
ich war alleine ich durfte niemand reden
ich hatte ein zuruf gang
ich durfte mit keinem gefängnis sprechen
und so weiter und das meine ich mit
vollständig isoliert was für mich als
legal 21 geworden einfach gewesen ist
das wurde später von raf-mitgliedern
dann immer als isolations folter
bezeichnet ja das wurde hat nur
bezeichnet das hätte das damals auf mich
bezogen selber nicht so bezeichnet
obwohl ist sehr schwer für mich damit
umzugehen aber ich bin ein jahr im
gefängnis gewesen ist mal was anderes
und in diesem jahr hatte ich kann die
viele anwalts besucher und ich hatte
auch den prozess gehabt und so weiter
spielen jetzt also nicht wie ulrike
meinhof einmal sechs monate in einem
stuhl oder sieben monate in einen toten
trakt gewesen ohne geräusche von draußen
usw
deswegen würde ich das nicht mit dem
vergleichen was später war aber das kind
viel werde jetzt glaube ich zu weit
führen aber die fragen danach und
insoweit hat das natürlich eine
bedeutung und in dem das war für mich
auch eine erkenntnis erkenntnis hab den
ersten brief den ich aus dem gefängnis
geschrieben habe in der damaligen art
wir waren immer sehr offen wer muss
immer zu allen bekannt wenn man sie
nicht versteckt und so weiter habe ich
gesagt das hätten wir alles vorher
wissen können eine hausbesetzung in der
bundesrepublik deutschland hat keinen
bestand wenn sie nicht durch die
illegalität abgesichert ist nicht und
wer nicht
die herrschenden eliten wenn sie nicht
angst haben müssten dass ihnen
irgendetwas schwer wiegen da wird es
droht dann werden sie alle mittel
einsetzen gegen uns wird für sie einfach
nur irgendwelche variablen sind auf die
sie drauf schlagen aber wenn das 1973
war und 1975 die besetzung in stockholm
war dass nach diesem jahr auch im
gefängnis der klare entschluss die ziele
und die vorstellung und den widerstand
kann ich nur mit gewalt ausüben
also ich glaube dass ich theoretisch das
schon vorher zu gesehen habe aber ich
hätte mir das selber persönlich nicht
ich hätte mir nicht die fähigkeit
zugebilligt oder die politische reife
zugebilligt damals selber bewaffnet zu
kämpfen wenn sie mit 23
in an bewaffneten kampf gegangen sind in
stockholm ist dass ihre persönliche
eigene entscheidung gewesen oder würden
sie heute im rückblick sagen das war
auch eine kollektive entscheidung oder
ich bin in einer gemeinschaft gewesen
mit anderen zusammen und wind von denen
mehr oder weniger mitgenommen worden in
diesem bewaffneten kampf denn es ist ja
ein unterschied ob ich sage ich lehne
das system ab und ich ziehe mich
entweder zum beispiel zurück das gibt es
ja auch oder ich kämpfe mit
demokratischen mitteln gegen ein solches
system oder ich sage das funktioniert so
nicht ich muss einen bewaffneten
widerstand leisten also ist ein großer
unterschied also mich hat niemand
angesprochen dass sie die illegalität um
die legalität kommen möchte
und niemand hat mich gerufen sondern ich
hab selber nach dem tod von über mainz
nach kontakten gesucht und das war für
mich für meine innere innere
glaubwürdigkeit vor mir selber ist es
wichtig gewesen dass ich konsequenzen
aus meinen erfahrungen gezogen habe die
mit dem tod von olga mainz verbunden
waren
der tod von holger meins ist für sie
auch bis heute eine klare gewalttätige
entscheidung des staates gegen ein
mitglied einer anti staatlichen oder
terroristischen organisation der tod von
holger meins ist für mich die hat für
mich die nachricht dass eine
grundsätzliche system oppositionelle
haltung keine existenzberechtigung hat
dass sie nicht geduldet wird und dass
man den tod lieber den tod des subjekts
in kauf nimmt als das subjekt sozusagen
in seiner radikalen haltung zu ertragen
ohne dass es eine vision darüber gab wie
etwas aussehen sollte unter dem begriff
start was kommen sollte wenn man diesen
staat eliminiert hätte abgeschafft hätte
mit mehr güter sind wir aber muss ich
ihnen sagen das ist damals anfang der
70er jahre auch breit in der diskussion
gewesen hat man sich auf markus gezogen
akku sagt gesagt die voraussetzungen
etwas radikal abzulehnen ist nicht dass
man sozusagen schon sagen kann was
danach kommt sondern das ist erstmal ein
prozess der ablehnung und in diesem
prozess der ablehnung trennt man sich
von bestimmten fesseln und man wird
sehen was kommen wird
also das ist nicht das ist nicht die
voraussetzung und es ist tatsächlich so
dass keiner von uns das würde ich auf
video für falsch gehalten sich eine
utopie entwickelt hätte so sollte eine
freie eine befreite gesellschaft später
aussehen man hat ja ganz bank
allgemeine grundsätze dass man musste
man wollte die eigentumsfrage stellen
sollte keine kein privateigentum an den
produktionsmitteln geben
das sollte eine radikale gleichheit auch
in der ökonomie geben nicht wenn sie ist
geschichtlich anschauen nicht das hat
sich von mir sondern sie ist lukac dann
gab es mit dem christentum die
gleichheit vor gott mit dem mit der
französischen revolution kam die
gleichheit vor dem gesetz
in die welt mit der russischen
revolution sollte sozusagen die koki
gleichheit das dass menschen auch im
alltäglichen leben durchgesetzt werden
und kommen so das hat irgendwie nicht
funktioniert aber das war ein
versprechen das da war und eine
erwartung die man die man hatte und da
wollte man da wollte man hin zu nicht
aber man hat ja jetzt keine vorstellung
und das ist auch aberwitzig mit den
wenigen leuten wie mir die wir sind wie
sieht jetzt die zukünftige gesellschaft
definieren aber die schattierungen
arbeite wo marcuse setzt er voraus dass
die situation unerträglich ist und dass
man diese situation ändern muss dann
auch wenn man keine vision hat von dem
was daraus entstehen soll
das ist eigentlich doch ein bisschen zu
wenig für das wenn man das mit anderen
revolution mit anderen positionen
vergleicht nachvollziehbar wenn sie
sagen es war eine situation in der man
gar nicht anders reagieren konnte
dennoch ist es ein unterschied ob das
als bewaffneter kampf ausgeführt wird
warum ihre entscheidung für diesen
bewaffneten kampf also marcuse hatten
eine auseinandersetzung mit adorno
gesagt dass er die studentenbewegung
kritisiert und hat zu sehen sie hat aber
zu einem download den satz gesagt ich
will die ganze geschichte nicht erzählen
wie das dauert zu lange ich sehe es gibt
eine physische psychische unmöglichkeit
für meine studenten und für die jungen
leute sich diesen verhältnissen
anzupassen wenn das jetzt stimmt und
dass ich finde das gibt unsere situation
wieder
auch versucht am anfang an zu sprechen
wenn es das ist dass es das dass man das
gefühl hat man gibt sich vollständig
preis wenn man sich sich anpassen dann
kann man dann muss man sich dem
entgegenstellen und in diesem sich
entgegenstellen
sie haben das ja selber angesprochen von
67 bei mir meinetwegen dann die
hausbesetzung oder der tod von allgemein
zu wandern ist es etwas anderes gewesen
dann ist ja eine dialektik da und ich
würde vielleicht um das etwas
verständlicher zu machen gerne auf
dieses für sich auf diese physische
psychische unmöglichkeit eingehen weil
ich nicht der meinung bin da wiederhole
ich mich dass ich sagen dass es einzelne
aktionen des staatsapparates sind es
auch nicht die behandelt die
hausbesetzung oder wie wir reagiert
worden ist oder die sehr brutale
haftzeit die ich erlitten habe die mich
letztlich zum bewaffneten kampf viel
gebracht haben sondern ich glaube dass
in der zeit nach ab mitte der 60er jahre
ist ein so genannten
modernisierungsschub in der gesellschaft
gab den wir erfahren haben oder
irgendwie intuitiv und die politiker
waren auch bewusst mitbekommen haben das
ist ein modernisierungsschub da geht der
kapitalismus sozusagen aus diesem
acht-stunden-tag heraus und und
unterwirft alle lebensbereiche oder
tendenziell sukzessive einen
lebensbereich nach dem anderen der
verwertung und das ist etwas gewesen was
wir gespielt haben wir haben gemerkt wir
werden unter diesen bedingt und
politischen verhältnissen so angepasst
dass wir uns selbst verlieren
untergekommen zu dem was ich heute
konstatieren und was ich mit jemandem
pasolini zb der das vielleicht sogar
genauer gesagt hat dass ich in der lage
bin zuzusagen dass die leute dazu
gebracht werden dass man früher eine
äußere repression struktur hat und heute
werden die leute so konditioniert dass
sie sich selber sozusagen freiwillig
sozusagen der verwertung und unterwerfen
und das ist etwas gewiss das hat in den
70er jahren mitte der 60er jahre
angefangen
das ist dann in den 70er jahren stark
geworden über diese modell deutschland
und mit dieser ganzen
modernisierungsprozesse die die es die
es gab und ist und sie sehen ja damals
hat es noch große kollektive gegeben und
heute finden sie den menschen vereinzelt
und alleine und individualisiert und
auch entwaffnet von allen in der
gesellschaft vor
und das ist etwas gewesen ich glaube
dass wir das damals entweder geahnt
haben und wir haben dazu bauen
bewusstsein entwickelt und deswegen
haben wir gesagt dass das wollen wir
nicht das machen wir nicht mehr
darstellen und mit allem entgegen und
stutzen sie darauf und dann kommen sie
natürlich in so einer situation dass sie
sagen dass das leben ist sozusagen das
sie nur noch ein appendix innerhalb der
kapitalistischen verwertung werden wenn
das dass das leben ist dann müssen sie
dazu auch einen radikalen bruch mit
ziehen und das ist das was man uns
vorgeworfen hat dass mit diesem buch
gezogen haben und dieser buch der muss
ja letztlich bewaffnet seien die
erweiterte kann man natürlich von heute
aus betrachten so wie es viele machen
innerhalb der bürgerlichen
geschichtsbetrachtung indem sie sagen da
sind paar idioten vom himmel gefallen
die haben dann wild in der gegend
herumgeballert oder sowas aber man
könnte es auch begreifen was steckt also
jenseits der militanz versteckter ein
allgemeiner triebkraft daher wollen wir
wollen ja über den den ideologischen
überbau oder den hintergrund sprechen
und der dazu gehört ja unter anderem die
tatsache dass auch in dieser zahl dinge
passiert sind in den 70er jahren die aus
ihrer sicht begründet haben warum man
diesen staatlich akzeptieren kann dass
gestern das aktuell gemacht aber solche
sachen der tod schon heute meint sie
haben die haben etwas dringend gemacht
die entscheidung das vorher dass man
gesagt hat wir müssen wir müssen zu
diesem kapitalismus dagegen gesellschaft
entwickeln und wenn sie dagegen
gesellschaft entwickeln
wie soll das gehen die talente die die
kann sich nicht innerhalb des systems
entwickeln sondern sie haben dieses
system als ein geschlossenes system und
wir haben damals gesagt wir machen ein
buch wir stellen uns außerhalb und das
kann am ende
mir leid das kann nun gewaltsamen
zusammenstößen das geht gar nicht anders
haben sie nicht trotzdem den eindruck
dass es eine ganze reihe von fragen gibt
die da nicht geklärt sind
die möglicherweise mit ihnen selber oder
mit den nachfolgegenerationen der af
nichts zu tun haben sollen die von außen
kommen sind hat man die raf auch
instrumentalisiert
sie sind nicht alleine auf dem feld die
anderen und und eine erkenntnis aus
dieser ganzen geschichte ist also auch
ein revolutionärer krieg den sie sie
führen
sie bestimmen nicht was am ende
rauskommt die anderen bestimmen auch mit
was rauskommt insoweit sind ein
irgendwie immer einflüsse da aber die
frage jetzt noch mal in diese richtung
gibt es leute die uns sozusagen denn
obwohl wir sie bekämpft haben die uns
bestimmt haben die würde ich heute noch
kategorisch mit nein beantworten
zumindest für die die ich kenne und für
die 70er jahre aber für die andere zeit
im gefängnis gewesen da kann ich kann
ich ihnen wenig sagen oder wir nicht
spekulieren aber aber in einem solchen
fall wo man zum beispiel den täter nicht
kennt kann man das noch nachvollziehen
kann man sagen okay den hat man nicht
finden können oder nicht erkennen können
nicht identifizieren können das ist ja
im falle mehrerer raf attentate so
gewesen weil wenn wir uns herrhausen zum
beispiel anschauen ist immer die frage
gewesen wer hat diese bombe fabriziert
kann die rf das überhaupt gewesen sein
da muss man ja warum jetzt nicht also
ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr diese diese
diese bombe gebaut hat oder ich habe
ungefähr im überblick wie sie
wahrscheinlich auch wer damals innerhalb
der raf gewesen dies aber warum sollen
die das nicht gemacht haben also sie
haben nicht den eindruck dass es eine
bewusste instrumentalisierung der
zu bestimmten zeitpunkt gegeben hat über
den verfassungsschutz oder über andere
staatliche organe umzusehen
man kann die raf quasi zu mehr
eskalationen bringen und damit auch
anders bekämpfen
ein dort hinein geben um einen schritt
zurück anfang der 70er jahre ablehnung
des kapitalismus in dieser form in der
entwicklung hat er sich aus ihrer sicht
so entwickelt hat er den menschen so
entmündigt so and individualisiert wie
sie das damals eingeschätzt haben und
ihre genossen und die frage auch können
sie sich eine derartige gewalttätige
opposition gegen dem start heute noch
einmal vorstellen
also ich glaube nicht daran dass sich
geschichte wiederholt und ich bin auch
dagegen dass ich etwas wiederholt und
ich bin auch nicht ich bin nicht dafür
dass sich unsere geschichte in ihren
trainer form wiederholt weil sie
definitiv auch gescheitert ist das aus
vielen gründen aber das was eingetreten
ist ist glaube ich schon immer als das
was ich damals erwartet habe und das ist
ja nicht nur diese individualisierung
oder ist diese diese diese ganz
entmündigung der leute die nichts zu
sagen haben sondern das hat sich ja das
gesamte klima in der gesellschaft nach
rechts verschoben nicht und früher waren
linke große kollektive in der welt
unterwegs und haben nach nachlegen einer
emanzipation für alle gesucht wenn sie
sich heute das anschauen dann sehen sie
sie haben nationalistische rechte
strömungen die teilweise faschistisch
sind von dem was sie artikulieren
also da sehen sie auf das sich die
entwicklung die hat sich ja nun doch
sehr deutlich verschlimmert und das ist
für mich das was sie heute sehen das für
mich ausdruck dessen dass die linke
verloren hat
und weil sie verloren hat und fall ist
darüber keinen emanzipatorischen weg
mehr in der geschichte gibt kommen heute
bewegungen zurück die rückwärtsgewandt
nach irgendwelchen lösungen suchen und
das halte ich für schrecklich und man
muss sich nur sowas anschauen hätten sie
immer netten schauen sie doch mal donald
trump an nur um einen namen zu nennen
die den dingen jeder heute im mund hat
der kann der mögliche präsident des
militärisch bergsten und ökonomisch
bergsten staates der welt werden und da
stehen sie doch heute vor der frage man
hat nach 45 gesagt so was wie adolf
hitler das damals nicht mehr geben das
wird es nicht geben aber sie wissen noch
gar nicht was da heute alles sozusagen
in der systementwicklung steckt und was
passieren
danke für das gespräch